tras el reciente y polémico viaje del
jefe de la diplomacia europea josep
borrell a moscú los cancilleres europeos
están reunidos hoy en bruselas para
abordar futuras de abstracciones de
nuevo a rusia la detención y
envenenamiento del líder opositor alexéi
navalni ha hecho pensar a los países
europeos que ahora mismo la deriva
autoritaria de rusia no tiene marcha
atrás por ello se están estudiando
nuevas sanciones contra altos cargos del
gobierno aunque algunos países sobre
todo del este están pidiendo también que
se incluya a oligarcas rusos cercanos al
presidente ruso vladimir putin pero es
algo que ahora mismo no se tiene
consenso sobre esta cuestión nos a
primera vez que la unión europea
aplicaría sanciones a rusia y ha
ocurrido por ejemplo con la elección de
la península de crimea considerada
ilegal por la unión europea también
sobre la guerra del este de ucrania y se
trataría sobre todo de evitar la entrada
a territorio europeo de estas personas
sancionadas o la congelación de bienes a
pesar de que las relaciones entre la
unión europea y rusia- estar
más tensas que nunca bruselas insiste en
que hay que mantener la puerta abierta
al diálogo con rusia